so it all came to life in a dark bar in
Madrid I encountered my colleague from
Miguel Michael mini and we were drinking
a few beers and like scientists do he
told me about his
work and he told me that he is
interested
in how mother rats lick their pups after
they were
born and I was sitting there and saying
this is where my tax dollars are wasted
on this kind of soft
science and he started telling me that
when the rats like humans lick their
pups in very different ways some mothers
do a lot of that some mothers do very
little and most are in between but
what's interesting about it is that when
he follows these pups when they become
adults like years in human life long
after their mother died they are
completely different animals the animals
that were licked and groomed heavily the
high licking and
grooming are not
stressed they have different sexual
behavior they have different way of
living than those that were not treated
as intensively by her
mother so then I was thinking to
myself is this
magic how does this work as geneticist
would like you to think perhaps the
mother had the bad mother Gene that
caused her pups to be stressful and then
it was passed from generation to
generation it's all determined by
genetics or is it possible that
something else is going on here so in
rats we can ask this question and answer
it so what we did is a cross fostering
experiment you essentially separate the
litter the babies of this rat at Birth
to two kinds of fostering mothers not
the real mothers but mothers that will
take care of them high licking mothers
and low licking mothers and it can do
the opposite with a low licking pups and
the remarkable answer was it wasn't
important What gene you got from your
mother it was not the biological mother
that defined this property of these rats
it is the mother that took care of the
pups so how can this
work I an
epigeneticist I'm interested in how
genes are marked by a chemical Mark
during embryogenesis during the time
where in the womb of our mothers and
decide which Gene will be expressed in
what tissue different genes are
expressed in the brain and in the liver
in the
eye and we thought is it possible that
the mother is somehow
reprogramming the gene of her Offspring
through her behavior and we spent 10
years and we found that there is a
Cascade of biochemical events by which
the licking and grooming of the mother
the care of the mother is translated to
biochemical signals that go into the
nucleus and into the DNA and program it
differently so now the animal can
prepare itself for Life Is Life to be
going to be harsh is it going to be a
lot of food are there going to be a lot
of cats and snakes around or will I live
in an upper class neighborhood where all
I have to do is behave well and proper
and that will gain me social
acceptance and now one can think about
how important that process can be for
our lives we inherit our DNA from our
ancestors the DNA is old it evolved
during Evolution but it doesn't tell us
if you are going to be born in Stockholm
where the days are long in the summer
and short in the winter or in Ecuador
where equal number of hours for day and
night all year round and that has such
an enormous amount on our physiology
so what we suggest is perhaps what
happens early in life those signals that
come through the mother tell the child
what kind of social world you going to
be living in it's going to be harsh and
you better be anxious and be stressful
or is going to be an easy world and you
have to be different is it going to be a
world with a lot of light or a little
light is it going to be a world with a
lot food or little food if there's no
food around you better develop your
brain to binge whenever you see a
meal or store every piece of food that
you have as
fat so this is good Evolution has
selected this to allow our fixed old DNA
to function in a dynamic way in new
environments but sometimes things can go
wrong for example if you're born to a
poor family and the signals are you
better binge you better eat every piece
of food you're going to encounter but
now we humans in our brain have evolved
have changed Evolution even faster now
you can buy a McDonald for
$1 and therefore the preparation that we
had by our mothers is turning to be M
adoptive the same preparation it was
supposed to protect us from hunger and
famine is going to cause obesity
cardiovascular problems and metabolic
disease so this concept that genes could
be marked by our experience and
especially the early life experience can
provide us a unifying explanation of
both health and
disease but is it true only for rats the
problem is we cannot test this in humans
because ethically we cannot administer
child adversity in a random way so if a
poor child develop a certain property we
don't know whether this is caused by
poverty or whe poor people have bad
genes so geneticists would try to tell
you that poor people are poor because
their genes made them poor epigenesist
will tell you poor people are in a bad
environment or a impoverished
environment that creates that phenotype
that
property so we moved to look into our
cousins the monkeys my colleague Steven
sui has been rearing monkeys in two
different ways randomly separated the
monkey from the mother and reared her
with a nurse in his surrogate motherhood
conditions so these monkeys didn't have
a mother they had a nurse and other
monkeys were reared with their nor
normal natural mothers and when they
were old they were completely different
animals the monkeys that had a mother
would not care about alcohol they were
not sexually aggressive the monkeys that
didn't have a mother were aggressive
were stressed and were alcoholic
so we looked at their
DNA early after birth and see is it
possible that the mother is marking
there is a signature of the mother in
the DNA of The Offspring these are day4
monies and what you see here is the
Modern Way by which we study epigenetics
we can now map those chemical marks
which we call methylation marks on DNA
at a single nucleotide resolution we can
map the entire genome we can now compare
the monkey that had a mother and not and
here's a visual presentation of this
what you see is the genes that got more
methylated are red the genes that got
less methylated are green you can see
many genes are changing because not
having a mother is not just one thing it
affects the whole way it sends the
signals about the whole way your world
is going to look like when you become an
adult and you can see the two groups of
monkey extremely well separated from
each
other how early does this develop these
monkeys already didn't see their mother
so they had a social experience do we
sense our social status even at the
moment of birth so in this experiment we
took placentas of monkeys that had
different social status what's
interesting about social rank is that
across all living beings they will
structure themselves by hierarchy monkey
number one is the boss monkey number
four is the peon and you put four
monkeys in a cage there will always be a
boss and always be a
peon and what's interesting is that the
monkey number one is much healthier than
monkey number four and if you put them
in a cage monkey number one will uh will
not eat as much monkey number four will
eat as much and what you see here in
this m ation mapping a dramatic
separation at Birth of the animals that
had a high social status versus the
animals that did not have a high St so
we are born already knowing the social
information and that social information
is not bad or good it just prepares us
for life because we have to program our
biology differently if we're in a high
or the low social
status but how can you study this in
humans so we can't do experiments we
can't administer adversity to humans but
God does experiments with humans and
it's called natural disasters so one of
the natural disasters the hardest
natural disaster in Canadian history
happened in my province of Quebec it's
the ice storm of
1998 we lost our entire electrical grid
because of an ice storm when the
temperatures were in the dead of winter
of Quebec - 20 to-30 and they were
pregnant mothers during that time and my
colleague suzan King
followed the children of these mothers
for 15 years and what happened was that
as the stress increased and here we had
objective measures of stress how long
you were without power where did you
spend your time was it in your
mothers-in-law apartment or in some uh
Posh country home so all these added up
to a social stress scale and you can ask
the question how did the children look
like and it appears that as stress
increases the children develop more
autism they develop more metabolic
diseases and they develop more
autoimmune diseases and we will map the
methylation state and again you see the
green genes becoming red as stress
increases the red genes becoming green
as stress increases an entire
rearrangement of the genome in response
to
stress so if we can program genes if we
are not just the slaves of the history
of our genes that they could be
programmed can we deprogram them because
epigenetic causes can cause diseases
like cancer um metabolic disease and
mental health diseases let's talk about
cocaine
addiction cocaine addiction is a
terrible situation that can lead to
death and to loss of human
life we asked the question can we
reprogram the addicted brain to make
that animal non-addicted anymore we used
a cocaine addiction model that
recapitulates what happens in humans in
humans you're in high school some
friends suggest you some cocaine you
take cocaine nothing happens months pass
by something reminds you of what
happened the first time time a pusher
pushes cocaine and you become addicted
and your life has changed in rats we do
the same thing my colleague Alia did he
trains the animals to get used to
cocaine then for one month no cocaine
and then he reminds them of the party
when they saw the cocaine the first time
by a cue the colors of the cage when
they saw cocaine and they go crazy they
will press the lever to get cocaine till
they die we first
determined that the differ difference
between these animals is that during
that time when nothing happens there's
no cocaine around their epig genome is
rearranged their genes are remarked in a
different way and when the CU comes
their genome is ready H to develop this
addictive phenotype so we treated these
animals with drugs that either
increase DNA mulation which was the
epigenetic Mark we look at or decrease
epigenetic uh markings and we found that
if we increase mation these animals go
even crazier they become more craving
for cocaine but we've reduced the DNA
metalation the animals is not addicted
anymore we have reprogrammed them and
the fundamental difference between an
epigenetic drug and any other drug is
that with epigenetic drugs we
essentially remove the signs of
experience and once they're gone they
will not come back unless you have the
same experience so the animal now is
reprogrammed so when we visited the
animals 30 days 60 days longer which is
in human terms many years of life they
were still not Addicted by a single
epigenetic
treatment so what we learned about DNA
the DNA is not just a sequence of
letters it's not just a script DNA is a
dynamic moving our EXP experiences are
being written into this movie which is
interactive you're like watching a movie
of your life with the DNA with your
remote control you can remove an actor
and add an actor and so you have in
spite of the terministic nature of
genetics you have control of the way
your genes look like and this has a
tremendous optimistic message for
ability to now encounter some of the
deadly diseases like cancer mental
health with new approach looking at them
as M adaptation that if we can gen
epigenetically intervene reverse the
movie by removing an actor and setting
up a new
narrative so what I told you today is
that our DNA is really combined of two
components two layers of information one
layer of information is old evolved for
millions of years of evolution it is
fixed and very hard to change the other
layer of information is the epigenetic
layer which is open and
dynamic and sets up a narrative that is
interactive that
allows us to control to a large extent
our destiny
to help the destiny of our children and
to hopefully conquer conquer
disease and and uh and uh serious health
challenges that have plagued humankind
for a long time so even though we are
determined by our genes we have a degree
of Freedom that can set up our life to a
life of responsibility thank you
m